hey guys i'm ryan right and though this
would be crazy we're gonna watch this
video today that I've been asked up the
[ __ ] to watch Dragon Ball Z light of
hope pilot I don't know what this is you
didn't watch Dragon Ball right no I've
actually never seen it when I was
younger I was like really into like YuYu
Hakusho and like other shows I never got
involved with Dragon Ball and I've been
meaning to it's been on this like crazy
long list of shows to watch but like I
have to finish a show completely before
I move on to the next it just never got
there I'm assuming this is another like
fan made short film Dragon Ball Z I did
watch a lot when I was like in third
grade I was on kcal9 like 6:00 in the
morning I don't remember a lot of it but
this video should be judged based off
its own merits not because of its link
to nostalgia stuff it should be based
off of its own merits I'm gonna have to
cut this halfway through just because
the camera will cut automatically this
is 13 [ __ ] minutes oh you're gonna
sit here with us and watch us sitting
and watching your video in it together
oh hey we're watching it together
Oh machinima nope right
okay begins would go to his death
changes
six months later they enter a pair of
heartless monsters with no regard for
life he's endured slightly Millions
only about ten dollars into the server
to the resistance
yeah along with my mentor Gohan and
myself together we always find a way
dark [ __ ] we got going on here
would you do
please
I'll do anything you want I love this
part everybody anymore looking at your
body to me I killed
this feels like a student film
side it here
by one soon
and Rachel's
looks better now I like to bourbon who's
next
top secret secret would you just kill
them already we spent all that time
rhyming about if I kill them all at once
where's the fun in that
let's make them run away that would be
more interesting I like that
good idea 18 I write you bourbon God run
along
I just don't like the sound it
that's fine
Oh
oh my god
the special effects are really good
looking on that
is that supposed to be
we need to buy more time
normally yes
yeah all right poor guys took too long
below the Kamiya
you
supera saying that [ __ ]
Oh
all right
ah I love that that was cool that was
cool
now as I go
nice long let's go
I'm so got chills
ow
Oh
Oh
to do this
thirteen years fighting his team
/ ah yeah
you
how's Jennifer Anniston for a second
we were just a side project I was going
along that because one optical channel
boy died
well so too
Hey my father keep telling more batter
holes you like
crowd ohh what of himself Dutchman's um
I think there is more to it than that
that's the same thing mom says it still
doesn't make sense
how could parlor Jack be a good thing
well maybe someday we'll all understand
but finale's concentrate okay
they were they weren't trading there
haha
next time on Dragon Ball Z light of hope
we are making a difference out there
I need my power get on a game without
first suffering the pain of loss
father like son
maybe actually more [ __ ] than what you
are with me Oh Supergirl is it going to
take advantages attention
but I Walter to people um okay but I
gotta say about it that I liked I really
liked and the other part of me is the
stuff that I'm like not sure how I feel
about is because I can't tell if it's
bad or if it's intentionally cheesy and
bad sometimes like the acting I was like
okay I kind of get what they're going
for like kind of that over-the-top
american dun ennemi kind of voice but
then at times I was like these are just
bad act I got confused as I was like
this is either just bad acting or I get
what they're going for so I didn't know
like yeah like any of them any of the
characters okay they had great action
sequences and that's when most people
did people are gonna come here mainly to
judge that like how did they pull off
the action scenes they were awesome like
I thought they were really [ __ ] cool
I loved they brought the cartoon to life
you know like with the way especially
the way it was shot the Comoros are so
[ __ ] sweet it was cool and like I
said before though like the special
effects whatever team they had working
on that it was pretty phenomenal I think
is I wish the work they put into making
those scenes so good is what they put
into the scenes of dialogue yeah I know
the dialogue I mean that's what yeah
like the dialogue was good the editing
and sound that was like really off I
don't think the sound is the problem I
think it was the same video frame me the
sound was too easy for me to like that
like the sound was never consistent oh
yeah they would change sound all the
time so it was it felt like [ __ ] in
different environments it felt like they
cut the camera and you know like when
he's on the beach it's like you hear the
water go Homer yeah they executed the
action and the visual effects awesomely
but the other stuff it like look like a
student film you by the way it was like
was weird because they got the fight
scenes the hardest part down exquisitely
but they couldn't get the drama down as
well but even though the drama the
dialogue wasn't necessarily executed
perfectly I feel like the actors they
chose were pretty great but really yeah
don't know that I think okay I think
that the actors they chose fit the
characters they're trying to portray
given I don't know this story and now
seeing this I wish I did could because I
don't feel like you know having never
seen it I don't feel like I have enough
knowledge of the backstory of the
characters to understand what was going
on
fully it gives me enough to enjoy it I
don't know I felt like there was a lack
of energy and belief in their
performances like especially with the
lead guy like I don't know [ __ ]
name's [ __ ] little IRA I'm going
based off this is why any short none of
them I felt were committed to the
over-the-topness of this world in their
performances unless they were fight but
when it came to their dialogue I felt
there should have been a commitment to
over-the-top so then it just ports came
across like bad acting instead Banri
nailed my emotional opinion down
perfectly perfectly so you do that after
a while you get good at turning your
opinions I see oh okay because you know
otherwise you just can't that's really
what built this channel my honest
opinion is that like overall 85 90
percent I loved it and it was really
entertaining super fun to watch the
editing was really good the special
effects were really good um you're right
I think it could have been a little
better on the dialogue I feel like the
sound mixing yeah it could have been a
little better however overall I feel
like they killed it it was yeah at the
end of the day this is meant for Dragon
Ball Z fans from what I remember I feel
like this will satisfy the fans yeah I'm
not a fan because I've never seen the
show but now because I've seen this I
want to see the show I want to know what
everything was going on right there and
I want to know the characters their own
backstories I'm going to become a fan
based on this I think that little kid's
gonna grow up and [ __ ] that blonde chick
good luck with that
no I'm serious I really they have a
YouTube channel I'm gonna contact them
give them an idea okay you do that it's
all about being creative to make it in
this business I've been doing it wrong
this whole time
anyway guys thanks for telling me that
video is out if you're new to the
channel you can subscribe to the real
rejects and alissa be crazy has a
channel that is growing so [ __ ] fast
right now
yeah you've gotta hop on the train and
see what everyone's [ __ ] talking about
seriously think I'm kind of worried that
she'll she'll get a bigger following
than me concerned about oh I feel like
you're growing too fast for any of us no
no nope nope I think that if you surpass
me in subscribers I will be jealous I'll
be angry at myself I don't know how to
fuel those feelings of oh I'm so proud
of them and no it's not about
competition when it really [ __ ] is is
such a lie oh and you can follow us on
Instagram and Twitter and the Facebook
the social network rule is the thing I
like about what we do for all three of
those things is that they're really
consistent and they're all like named
the same thing or really close to the
same thing so follow us there are
benefits when we get a lot of followers
you post fun things it's okay that I
mentioned that there are benefits if we
get a lot of followers I don't know
No well it's in the video now oops
check out our social networks shoutouts
will continue but since this is already
such a long video just go to
facebook.com slash the real reject
shoutouts where you can earn yourself a
shout out by saying something
interesting like Bryan's mouth kind of
looks like a vagina hmm mercy
yeah yeah it kind of does vagina yeah so
your behind with